hello he is the champion my friend yes
girl
keep going and then you can sing to it
how about that how about that yeah oh
man hey I am over the moon about all of
this
this is especially at rewarding
considering how hard it is one to be an
actor it's a point point zero one
percent of us get to do this and I get
to celebrate this not only on behalf of
Queen and Freddie but everyone who has a
wish and desire to fulfill their dreams
when you just won this tonight I thought
about what you just said to me on the
red carpet like you got your sag card by
I'll hop on a bus and be there in ten
minutes I just need four lines right she
asked me she said she said hi can I
speak to rami malek Sager I said
speaking and she said can we get him
over to the office and I said listen
I'll be there in a heartbeat she said so
it's you and do you have your sag card
and I said no but we can work on that
and we can work on we having an agent -
I told you all this before but you got
those forward line yeah
but I want to give it back to you and
reiterate it yeah I got that and even
after that it was still years of
struggle I have my Sankar but it was
still almost I don't know maybe two
years before I have my next job so this
is proof that you can accomplish your
dreams you know that I do know that now
hey we have we've been doing all night
this question train so we've been having
other actors ask a question to us what
they would want to ask to an actor so
the next person that comes up to us we
asked that actor that question aquafina
was the last one her question that I'm
asking you is how are you taped in how
my were taped in
I did I did I do
I do you some double-stick every once in
a while but I won't tell you where and
how how about that
[Music]